wird die erde gerade für die landung von
aliens vorbereitet immer wieder hören
wir vom terraforming der methode um
einen planeten mars in eine zweite erde
zu verwandeln mit wasser atmosphäre und
an pflanzen tieren und so weiter und so
fort es könnte paradiesisch werden auf
einem so ganz neu zu einer zweiten erde
verwandeln planeten
dagegen müssen wir hier bald unseren
heimatplaneten verlassen wenn es so
weitergeht was passiert also auf der
erde alien forming die vorbereitung der
landung einer anderen spezies jetzt sind
klicks und science fiction herzlich
willkommen
eigentlich ist es schon ein bisschen
verrückt stephen hawking der sagt dass
wir schon bald die erde verlassen müssen
es wird nämlich wenn wir so weiter
machen ziemlich ungemütlich auf unserem
heimatplaneten nun auch allen masc meint
dass wir den mars und weitere planeten
im sonnensystem besiedeln müssen dabei
ist es dann noch viel lebensfeindlicher
als bei uns auf der erde terraforming
also die verwandlung dieser
himmelskörper in zweit erden soll es
unter anderem möglich machen und das ist
wirklich paradox was passiert hier wir
zerstören unsere erde um dann andere
lebensfeindlichen planeten zu besiedeln
das ist wirklich seltsam oder ist das
alles schicksal quasi vorbestimmen ich
habe mir dazu mal ein paar gedanken
gemacht und das ist wirklich etwas
befremdlich also ein gedankenexperiment
es gibt ein paar indizien die ziemlich
wahrscheinlich machen das ist parallele
entwicklung der revolution hier auf der
erde aber auch im ganzen universum gibt
hier auf der erde und das finde ich
ziemlich verrückt haben sich alle
zivilisationen ähnlich entwickelt alle
haben irgendwann städte gebaut den
pflanzenbau kultiviert tiere gehalten
religionen gegründet alle überall egal
wo es ist als gäbe es ein
entwicklungsmuster als wäre das alles
vorprogrammiert das ist es
wahrscheinlich nicht sondern eine folge
unserer begrenzten intelligenz wir
wissen nicht was um uns herum passiert
und müssen uns in religionen flüchten um
das überhaupt annähernd begreifen zu
können was wir aber immer noch nicht tun
und wir begreifen offenbar selbst die
einfachsten zusammenhänge nicht und
einer davon ist entscheidend das
verbrennen fossiler brennstoffe führt
zwingend zur unbewohnbar machen der erde
denn was passiert pflanzen haben co2
gebunden der sauerstoffgehalt stieg
durch diese bindung diese pflanzen
wurden durch geologische bewegungen
unter mächtigen schichten begraben
dadurch wurde das co2 dauerhaft ja
begraben und der atmosphäre entzogen
die erde wurde für unsere spezies
bewohnbar unsere spezies entwickelt sie
sich jetzt kehren wir diesen prozess
aber um und machen die erde wieder für
uns unbewohnbar wir holen das gebundene
co2 aus der erde und pusten es in die
luft ist scheint mir genau so zwingend
wie die gründung von religionen dass das
machen schließlich wurde auch das feuer
nicht an einem ort entdeckt sondern von
verschiedenen völkern parallel und dann
in folge eben auch die verbrennung von
fossilen brennstoffen
das ist ja auch ganz logisch und
zwingend in der abfolge und fast
unabänderlich jede spezies hätte das
genauso getan und wenn sich jetzt
vielleicht ja bei der entdeckung der
alien mikroben zeigt dass ich leben auch
auf anderen himmelskörpern sehr ähnlich
entwickelt dann wäre das eine wirklich
meint blume erkenntnis es gäbe quasi ein
gesetz wie sich leben im universum
entwickelt und ist es quasi vor bestimmt
wie das in stufen abläuft aber in
welcher stufe sind wir und warum machen
wir das sind wir vielleicht eine
zwischenstufe und es gibt noch einen
viel größeren plan
es ist quasi vor bestimmt dass wir hier
genau das machen automatisch wie ein
ameisenstaat aber was machen wir dann
bereiten wir die erde vielleicht ganz
automatisch auf die landung von aliens
vor
diese dann besiedeln werden wenn wir das
klima so verändert haben dass sie darauf
existieren können ich finde die idee
ehrlich gesagt nicht ganz so absurd wenn
ich mir unsere entwicklung so bis heute
ansehe allerdings kann es auch ganz
profan sein wir sterben aus und eine
andere spezies ameisen echsen oder
ähnliche übernehmen die führung auf
jeden fall scheint sich da ein
zwingendes muster zu zeigen dass wir nur
noch nicht so ganz erkennen wohin geht
es also wir können darüber leider nur
spekulieren aber vielleicht wird uns ja
der erste kontakt mit aliens die augen
öffnen er soll ja laut nasa schon bald
also den nächsten 20 jahren stattfinden
bzw
geht die nasa davon aus dass wir schon
bald aliens entdecken werden ich bin
schon ziemlich gespannt wenn ihr also
als erster neues zum thema aliens und zu
allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video eben vor ab und
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der
redaktion von pixum mitmachen und mir
themen vorschlagen oder andere
vorschläge machen
der direkte draht zu mir oder abstimmung
machen wir da auch einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit der genau vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken aliens der erste kontakt ja
ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran